Speaker 1: So I have not talked about the
AOC Miami trip because, quite frankly,
I find it all pretty, pretty uninteresting.
But a bunch of you have asked me to comment
on the coverage of it, and I do think there
are a couple of interesting things there. So
the back story on this as I understand it and
again, I care so little about it that I'm more
interested in the reaction than the story as
I understand it. Over the New Year's weekend,
Democratic Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
and her her partner, her boyfriend, her husband.
I don't know the guy, the guy she's with. They
went down to Miami. I think she has family there,
and she was photographed eating outdoors without
a mask. Some right wing commenters focused on
the fact that she went. She escaped liberal New
York and D.C. to go to conservative Florida. OK,
not a super interesting analysis. I mean,
Miami is like the most left place in Florida.
I love Miami myself. I would never live
in the conservative parts of Florida,
but I love Miami. I love the food, I love the
weather. I love the diversity of people. And,
you know, speaking Spanish with all the
Cuban-Americans that are down there you are
lots of Argentineans. I don't know that it's any
big indictment on conservatism, on liberalism that
you go to Miami. It's one of the most liberal
places, especially eastern Miami-Dade County.
The other some people focused on the fact that
her partner was wearing sandals and you could
see his feet. It was very, very strange. And then
AOC shot back. A lot of these people that are mad,
they actually they actually want to date me,
which I thought it was a little bit weird,
a little bit pompous and presumptuous, but I
just don't really care about it. But a very
interesting thing happened, which is that on Fox
News reporter Charlie Gasparino actually said,
To be honest with you, the criticism AOC is
getting is unfair. And the anchor didn't like
it and started arguing with Charlie Gasparino,
who was just very honest. Take a look at this.
The entire segment is called Rules for the Not for
me, by the way, and AOC was eating outside without
a mask. I mean that that's allowed everywhere. I
don't even know what what is unfair about that.
Speaker 5: Well, it seems AOC is A-OK with
ditching the mask when in Miami, at least
Speaker 1: she's sitting outside. But what does
that mean? She's OK? What are you talking about?
Now there's video of her outside hugging someone.
Speaker 5: Well, that was the New York
congresswoman music playing in the background,
partying up, dropping the cover while partying
at that crowded bar there in Florida. Critics
are calling her a hypocrite as COVID cases spiked
back in her home state of New York. Charlie.
Speaker 1: And by the way, cases are spiking
in Florida, too, but hospitalizations are
up 200 percent. Like even the whole framing
is crazy. But let's get into the meat.
Speaker 5: Reno joins us now. So, Charlie,
is it fair that many are calling her out
for being a hypocrite while partying it
up in Florida while her home state
is battling a record COVID surge?
Speaker 4: To be honest with you, I know. Yeah,
it is unfair. I don't see why. Why she can't go
to Florida and have a good time. I mean, I
kind of wish I were. Nobody said she should.
I was. I was in college. I was in quarantine.
Speaker 1: So what exactly is the hypocrisy? Is
it she wasn't wearing a mask outside because
basically no one is. Is it that she went to
a different? What is the hypocrisy exactly?
Speaker 4: It's a park. It's it's a it's a
it's a it's a hypocrisy. If she's sitting around
talking about what a bad job DeSantis is doing,
the governor DeSantis of Florida is
doing as opposed to what a great job.
Governor Hochul in New York is doing, then it
would be hypocritical for her to go and party
in the place in the center of of evil.
Speaker 5: Let me make this
a little dirty, which a lot of Democrats do.
Speaker 1: The anchor does not like that.
Charlie Gasparino is off message here.
Speaker 5: Charlie, she's been very supportive
of very strict measures in her home state to
fight the coronavirus pandemic. Florida Many
Democrats have been very critical of Florida.
That has been more relaxed on some of those
measures. She is choosing to vacation there and
leave it up without her mask on and kiss and hug.
That's basically the sacristy being this.
Speaker 4: This is a Fox News alert. I am
going to support AOC on this, and
here's why she was outside. I mean,
I don't think she's unless she could show me some,
some tweet or some some statement from her saying,
I think people, even outside when they go jogging,
when they eat outside, should have a face mask on,
then it's not hypocritical because she's outside.
Speaker 1: And by the way, you can be critical of
Florida in terms of its lack of access to testing
because you would like to see schools take some.
If you go to Miami and sit
outside at a restaurant,
you're not really being hypocritical. I mean, it's
just it's what what was incredible was the degree
to which this was story number one on Fox News. I
mean, look, look at some of the coverage of this.
Speaker 5: Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez accused of hypocrisy.
Speaker 4: Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez of hypocrisy
Speaker 5: rules for the but not for me,
AOC, AOC, AOC Maybe AOC needs to go back
to the border. Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez, Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
Speaker 4: Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
Speaker 5: Alexandria
Ocasio-Cortez, The Heat AOC is
Speaker 1: getting. By the way, this
is all within a seven hour period.
Speaker 4: Of Cortez so-called squad member.
Speaker 5: Furthermore, I want to talk about AOC
Speaker 4: Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez saying
Speaker 5: she's looking to we're like,
hot for her body, Brian.
Speaker 4: The Motley Crue
song Right? The girl. Don't go away,
man. Just go away. Don't come down
here. Why are you coming out here?
Speaker 5: AOC says that you just
are. You just are sexually frustrated.
You want to date her, that you want to
date communist. So tell me about that.
Speaker 4: She says they're mad because
they can't date her. Sean Duffy.
Speaker 1: Now I do. I do admit that
they're mad because they can't date or it comes
off as a little bit arrogant. It's probably true
with some of them, by the way. It's probably,
but it's not the type of thing you're supposed
to say. So another fabricated story. And again,
I do think Charlie Gasparino is right. If she was
indoors at some big concert with no mask, I think
it would be different. But many of us all along
have been saying there should be testing. We're
fine with vaccine mandates. You should wear masks
indoors, Baa Baa Baa Baa Baa, but no one's really
getting this outdoors and sitting outdoors. And in
fact, going to a warm place and where it's easier
to sit outdoors seems like a completely coherent
thing to do, given that belief. I'm not even a big
defender of AOC, but this was very, very stupid.